cantagnos was a typical rural village of
a few hundred families
it had rice fields a church and a school
now it's the scene of some of the
biggest devastation in the philippine
it sounded like an explosion we ran up
to the hill to see what was going on it
was awful we could hear people crying
calling out for
help tropical storm maggie brought
incessant rains in the eastern visayas
region many areas have lost power and
communication lines
but cantagnos was the most devastated
survivors here tell us there were two
landslides the first one was at around 5
a.m which gave some time for some
families to evacuate but the second one
they say they saw how waves of mud came
rolling down the mountains burying
hundreds of civilians this is all what's
left of it now
on the other side of the hill four
bodies have been pulled out from the
rubble
government responders are doing the best
they can
but their efforts have been hampered by
more rain the mud is at least five
meters deep so they will have to wait
before they can bring in heavy equipment
all visible
we could only get bodies in the
periphery because it is dangerous even
for our men i think this process of
retrieval will take time
flowers and incense are offered and the
souls
all
the peoples
and the prayer for those who remain
buried
and unaccounted for
lent is meant to be a week of gratitude
and grace for millions of filipino
families but for the survivors of the
landslide in cantagnos this period will
now remind him of their overwhelming
grief
jamal allendogen al jazeera bye bye lady
province central philippines